can she come to the window coronavirus
has divided families as care homes go
into lockdown to protect their residents
Edith is 91 with dementia and can't
understand her daughter's reluctance to
join her the care assistants do their
best to distract her and the others at
this home the care assistants have moved
in so they can keep the virus out
leaving their own families to care for
the elderly relatives of others to do so
you know there's people that have been
in the real you know these been midwives
and you know they fall for our country
and by doing this it was fighting for
them but others are suffering 14
residents have now died in a fortnight
after an outbreak at Oak Springs home
around the corner with 2/3 of staff off
ill at one stage including the manager
she told us before she went sick that
they were battling on and she couldn't
praise her staff highly enough they're
under great strain she said one relative
whose grandmother is inside but who
asked to remain anonymous likened it to
her being trapped in a fire and he
couldn't save her one of the local MPs
says the elderly are being sacrificed in
this pandemic everybody's life should be
valued equally it just imagined care
whether you are a hundred and eight or
whether you are ten your life is as
valuable when you are young as when you
are old we have all contributed to
society these people deserve the optimum
Channel
it's off survival and we've got to do
everything in our power to ensure that
they are safeguarded one care assistant
working in a home with an outbreak
didn't want to be identified but told us
of lack of PPE panic and fear as they
cope with rising deaths even though I
was at home Mother's Day and I've seen
that before
I have never laid on the old and on one
day I laid two out in an hour and
nothing could prepare you for that I can
see people operating queen and if you
like people might mark this by PTSD I
felt guilty of it felt like ninepins be
home I've not been elbow I've been
shopping and things like that did I
think it could I'd them wrong it's just
yeah it's been the hardest time ever
that's me dad jeans mother in happier
times when she was fit and healthy if
she does get coronavirus now her only
daughter doesn't want her resuscitated I
mean there are young people there not
that I'm saying that son don't think
camping mercenary there obviously she's
mine won't want to keep her as long as
possible but I would hate for us to go
that and I know that she was hated to
she'd prefer a younger person to be
saved yeah definitely
at beachside home they know once the
virus gets in it'll be catastrophic
it's not easy obviously if it did come
in here the chances of like survival
it's horrible it's like it's very slim
so it's it would be like traumatic for
everyone cause they are your family for
now their approach has kept the virus at
bay but for how long
Alex Crawford Sky News Liverpool